oh welcome to mavis beacon teaches
typing powered by ultrakey family
edition
this spoken support can be changed
turned off or set to automatic
managers see preferences when you are
logged into management when users log in
they should review the options and
speech menus
wow okay
i'm just gonna welcome
do you remember this is this hitting a
specific part of your memory or have you
approached this recently
this is mavis records on the local
computer are displayed open your record
this is mavis beacon teaches typing and
the reason that i'm leaving the voice on
is because when i learned how to type i
used mavis beacon teaches typing i
believe seven this doesn't even have a
number anymore and now there's a 2020
edition but i'm not going to use that
that's too modern i want to go back into
your first name and your last name
the name you entered the program is
about to create a new record for you
yeah welcome
for an introduction to keyboarding with
this software click the movie button
introduction to mavis beacon teaches
typing
no to assess your typing goal complete
the assess level activity
use the options menu to match the
program
i remember mavis talking to me but i
don't remember it occurring this much
but i want you to take in the
environment really soak it in look deep
into your screen and see the background
smell
the late 90s aesthetic of the cg in this
place look at this
4x3 monitor that it is in look at the
window in which we are looking out into
the world all of this just screams
[Music]
late 90s early 2000s so i'm going to
assess my level because
level is a speed and accuracy you will
aim for as you learn
to set the best level for you you will
type a short passage of text relax
the program will set a goal that is just
a little better than you type now okay
good so it's been a while since i've
taken a typing test i don't remember how
much i was typing back then i think i
topped out a ring maybe like 70 80 words
per minute which is pretty good but i've
been typing ever since then and i'm
assuming that i'm a little bit better
but i don't know so i'm going to assess
and i'm gonna leave mavis on
i don't care if you want to do this for
yourself without the voice this is
authentic to the experience because i
remember mavis talking to me get ready
all your warheads raise your hands over
home row
and check your posture
strike the space bar when you are ready
to begin your assessment i'm ready to
begin my assessment
begin when ready to hear the material
read aloud highlight the text
animal call
called the
oh god uh the
platypus is part man oh god and part
bird
it has a body like a beaver and a bill
and feet like duck a mother blab
god i keep getting that wrong gives milk
like all mammal mothers do
she lays eggs like all bird mothers do
there are many
other
examples of
curious creatures in the world
i'm
done and the test was stopped by
striking the end key yes i know i i did
that errors are highlighted so you can
see any patterns i know you wouldn't let
me backspace which i think was also a
thing in the mavis beacon because oh i
get in such a habit of backspacing but
oh look at me what's my assessment if
you are satisfied with your results
move on by striking the space bar
you can try the assessment again by
clicking the redo button actually not
bad growth speed 75 words per minute
accuracy 96 when you look at it like
that that's not too bad but my net speed
is 53 words per minute effectively
without with all the errors however i
was not ready for it so i could have
done better but now
has been set as shown
in skill check you have to reach this
challenge level to pass
adjust your level by choosing challenge
level from the options menu
okay thanks excellent timing begins with
correct body and hand position
click the posture button
posture teaches you correct body and
hand position okay good posture is
needed for expert keyboarding and to
prevent strain you're right i'm going to
be an expert keyboarder the movie button
introduction to possible movie
oh god look at this
wow
intro to posture developing good posture
habits is the first step in learning to
keyboard
this is because
positioning your body and preventing it
from moving around are both needed for
accurate typing
everything we do and how well this is
not good
our bodies okay
the posture module lets you explore good
keyboarding posture using a virtual
reality model a virtual reality model
click i don't know if that's what that
is hold
and drag the mouse
to view the model from different
positions oh
i think i'm good for a larger view of
good posture open the posture vr movie
found on the movies menu
when you think you know the key points i
have a quiz oh no okay wait here we go
okay here we go
what
oh right only on apple can i get the vr
version i'm on scuzzy pc
dirty and
boring and gross literally i don't think
anybody who types ever types like this
with claw hands on keyboard but um i'm
gonna do my best this is a great video
great stuff thank you okay next this is
this is not good posture
move on to see good posture i don't know
that's pretty much what i do all the
time i don't know about you guys but i
feel like that's my posture i feel like
as a default i am always that
this is good posture
move on to learn correct body and hand
position
good
posture great posture actually
the model shows correct posture
click the arrows to discover posture
facts double click
i want to unsubscribe from posture facts
[Music]
it's puzzle time
god i don't remember doing this click on
the model where i see
unsafe's posture well
the footies are all wrong the fingies
are all in the head is all forward and
the shoulders are all slouched the back
is sloped and honestly too close to the
monitor all right let's go with that
hunchback
so you can comfortably look over the top
of the screen
over the top why why is that important
why is that important okay what about
the fingies keep your elbows close to
the body
why this keeps your arm stable and your
wrists at the correct angle what i
thought what's about the wrist rest you
know the wrist rest what about these
footies
keep your feet on the floor if you
cannot reach the floor get a foot stand
or lower your chair
okay i reached the floor what about the
butt
center your body in front of the g and h
keys
[Laughter]
okay all right how about this uh
monitor
keep your wrist parallel to the keyboard
if you need to put the keyboard on your
lap or tilt the keyboard so your wrists
are parallel to it
okay
relax your shoulders
you should never feel tense when you
keyboard
i feel tense
keep your knees square so your body is
stable blood should be able to flow
easily through your upper leg how in are
you you're like it sounds like you're
gonna send me through a gravity machine
you're gonna spin me around until the
g's make me pass out
neck head hair nose uh shoulders boobs
okay was boobs
congratulations you have identified all
eight keys to correct posture
check your posture every time you
keyboard
all right you should now complete the
fingers module here we go everybody just
hold on to your butts everybody ready
center your body lean forward slightly
head up relax shoulders elbows close
knees square feet on the floor wrists
flat
don't you feel like a proper typist now
you wish you were as good as mavis but
you will never be you have finished
posture you should now complete the
fingers module i wanna
be a perfect finger master fingers
teaches you correct striking technique
the names of your fingers and correct
hand position
this prepares you for lessons
for an introduction click the movie
button introduction oh i do need the
movie about fingers i really do i like
the posture the fingers module prepares
you for the main lessons
parents you can require the posture and
fingers activities by setting the
sequence control in the preferences
found in the management area
fingers introduces three key concepts
striking technique
the names of the fingers
and the home row position
your experience begins with video of a
real ultra key graduate wow
after viewing the sample video you learn
each of the finger names
as the lessons introduce new keystrokes
your fingers will be referred to by name
the fingers are named after their home
keys which form the home rule this is
pointer this is pointer
this is jay
and your fingers into their positions
every
single
time
ever when you see get ready
you will know exactly what that means
so let's get ready by enjoying and
learning from the fingers activity
wow
[Laughter]
okay man i'm gonna be such a good type
or
finger closely watch how an experienced
typist strikes the keys
[Music]
i'm watching notice
the typist moves her hands as little as
possible
the less her hands move the less energy
she uses and the better she types
she does not press the keys
she strikes them quickly
and cleanly
double double-click or right-click the
movie to play it i don't need to
thank you let's learn the names of your
fingers
didn't i take the assessment test wasn't
it wasn't it clear that i knew how to
type your pointer finger is called f
because its home position is the f key
oh
i mean f
the other three fingers are also named
after their home keys strike f again to
see all the names
your left hand fingers are called a
s
d d
f f
i know f
a
s
d f
as strike the a key
strike s
strike d
step
place your right hand on the keyboard as
shown yeah
your right hand fingers are named after
their home keys
j j k k
l l
semicolon
it is just called thumb
it's the space bar
watch the space bar
use your thumb when all fingers are on
their home keys the hands are in home
row position
okay
all right i'm ready
gotcha of each hand anchored on its home
key while you keyboard
strike this
as each name is highlighted
j s
l
thumb
f thumb a
l l
thumb s l s k
f
thumb k s s l
[Music]
i'm ready
[Applause]
now you know your finger names and how
to strike the keys
you are ready for lessons
the lessons module teaches new keys
for best results
take a lesson and then use skill check
can i just do i know the keys i swear i
do guys current settings require you to
complete at least one lesson before
using skill check let me get an
introduction to lessons i i want to know
[Music]
mavis beacon teaches typing introduces
three to four keystrokes at a time using
13 sequined lessons
each lesson has distinct steps
when starting your first session of the
day take a warm-up
and limber up your fingers
you will be given simple exercises for
each new the hands twink from the
stretches menu one time what whoa hold
on hold the hold this way
knowing when and how to take stretch
breaks is a part of learning to type
is it
is it
you can also select stretch sequences
from the stretches menu anytime
stretch stretch
stretch arms and neck do you have aching
muscles or feel tense i mean yeah
stretch breaks relieve all of that so
you can continue keyboarding in comfort
keyboarding
start by raising your hands like the
model you see and wiggle your fingers
keep your arms up
oh
i have to do like this a tingling
sensation as
blood flows up and down your arms what
tingling sensation
and again and again
remember you should stand up and stretch
any time you feel pain or tension
what if i feel pain and tension all the
time
should i always be standing and wiggling
my fingers
let's continue this stretch by gently
flexing your neck what
right
right
pause
my camera's mirrored don't worry i know
my right and left left
[Music]
pause this is so not what i real slow
i don't know what's happening forward
forward
pause
never flex your neck back because that
can squeeze tiny bones and nerves
easy does it
i screw you i'm doing it anyway
pause
keep it real
slow
this is actually
this is fantastic i thought i was going
to be typing today it turns out i
learned my fingies and also stretches
nicely done
thank you
here comes the wave
encore i wonder if this company still
exists a navarre corporation company
that's great
that's great on arms and shoulders
forward
back
keep it gentle if any muscles are sore
roll just enough so you don't feel pain
forward
back
slow
slow
forward
back
very nice thank you before you sit down
take one deep breath
and let it all out
look i know that if i had
been doing this all my life
given that i've been in front of a
computer pretty much every day of my
life
since i first got in front of a computer
i know that my posture would be better
and i would not have any back pain i
know this so i'm going to take all this
to heart and i'm going to make sure that
i do these every day through mavis
beacon from now on
left
pause
center
center
pause
right
pause
[Music]
and again
all right
here comes the wave everybody
i'm just gonna go into this choose a
lesson step
i can only choose one
get ready
what place your hand the a key is struck
with the a finger
watch the screen before you type type
the a key to go on
type the a key and a space
watch the screen and keyboard this line
s space
the s key is struck with the s finger
type the s key and a space
watch the screen and keyboard what you
see
the d key is struck with the d finger
watch the screen and keep that good
posture
type the d key and a space
say the letters in your mind to help you
remember
lexi and put the letters in my mind
the f key is struck with the f finger
check your hands
[Music]
to move to the next step
keep both hands on the keyboard as you
watch and type
[Music]
please
miss beacon mrs beacon
the k key is struck with the k finger
as you strike the right hand keys keep
the left hand in position oh no
to go on mavis beacon would never crash
on me type the semicolon key to go on
key and a space
slow down and feel the keys you're
almost there
uh slow down okay
semicolon space
semicolon space
semicolon space
semicolon space
semicolon space
semicolon space
semicolon space
semicolon space
semicolon space
semicolon space
semicolon space
the enter key is struck with the
semicolon finger which returns quickly
to home row the enter key can be a
stretch for small fingers but the j
finger hangs on to its home position
type the enter key to move on
practice striking the enter key followed
by its home key the semicolon enter
semicolon
and
enter semicolon and semicolon
now you are ready to work with words and
break okay sentences
finish stretching it's a stretch break
guys we're gonna go
neck and trunk that's what i think i
need
right
pause
[Music]
left
pause
forward
pause
never flex your neck back because that
can squeeze
let's complete this stretch with a
gentle no okay strike space bar i'm
ready these words use letters learned so
far
relax and take your time as you type
them okay
that's not a word
ads it is a word
asks
ask ask
dad
lads sad sad dad dad
you have finished step two now keyboard
sentences ask dad semicolon
ask dads
let's ask all dad semicolon
hold on lads ask all dads semicolon add
salad semi-colon add salad
we need more salads
i'm alfalfa semicolon the salad needs
alfalfa
ask lad semicolon ask the lads for more
alfalfa all fall salads ask flasks alas
semicolon
all fall salads ask flasks alas
[Applause]
terrific hey
you have completed the lesson so you are
ready to practice with skill check check
my skills choose a skill check that
matches a comp
choose a skill check passage that
interests you
florida
what about florida you have chosen a
passage
now choose a length or time for the
skill check
paragraph i'm ready yes place your hands
over home row
and check your posture ready begin when
ready
florida
entered the union on march 3rd
1845 oops as the 20th heaven hate
the main growth began in the early 20th
century and by the night oh i got it it
had a diversified economy
[Applause]
congratulations
your challenge level
yeah yeah
wow review this chart to assess your
progress that's pretty good compare your
speed and accuracy goals to the results
on this skill check that's pretty good
well done
you had very few errors in your typing
thank you
choose a skill check passage that
interests you you have chosen a passage
how about entire choose a length let me
do the entire passage i got this one the
stone age get ready ready long ago
during the stone age life was
very different men women and children
did not live the way we live today they
did not live in
houses as we do
they did not know how to read or write
they could not go to the grocery stores
when they were hungry or clothing stores
when they needed to protect
themselves from the weather
the stone age people were mainly hunters
uh
excuse me
they moved from place to place trying to
find food to survive
after they killed
an animal they would eat the meat then
make clothes from the animal's skins
tools were sometimes made from the
leftover animal bones they did not know
how to grow food
so they
searched for wild berries and nuts to
eat
the stone age people lived outdoors or
in
caves
they felt the heat of summer and the
cold of winter these people of long ago
learned to use fire for cooking warmth
light and protection against
the wild animals at night
archaeologists have helped us learn
about these people of long ago
an archaeologist
is a person who digs
into the earth
while digging they find different
artifacts from the past they study the
objects they
find and by doing so
they have learned how people looked and
lived long ago during the stone age
there were too many errors to report
or you did not type the selected length
of material
please try again
[Music]
i don't want to drag it all right get
ready for floor
i'm gonna do it my way i was doing that
the posture way i'm actually going to
not do that
begin when ready flora
one second
check my posture i'm going to
florida
[Music]
your errors are highlighted oh my god
that's such a chart to access
sucked my accuracy was still somehow 96
that is nuts okay but it was because it
was accuracy remained okay but it
dropped just oh shush
shush choose a sk sure
she'll check passage that interests you
shush it's because there were so many
parentheses and numbers i don't like
those you've chosen
[Music]
here we go
get ready begin when
[Music]
ready choose a skip choose it you have i
got this
begin when ready
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh god my caps lock
no
there were too many oh it's because of
the caps locks oh you did not type the
selected links oh
no go back
open record open record hold
i'm good to go
[Music]
your errors are highlighted so you can
see any patterns oh my god
huh review this chart net speed
86
that is net speed in accounting for my
errors which is pretty good
great
you improved your accuracy and increased
your speed
i did it and now that i did that i want
to do one more i'm just going to do the
first paragraph i'm going to try to get
100 accuracy as fast i can
damn
it
damn it
[Music]
100 accuracy was out the window 90
and i want to do an assess level i want
to do this again
i'm assessing
[Music]
the test was stuck your errors are gross
made a hundred satisfied with your
results
100.
you can try the assessment again by
clicking the redo button
my god
the typing form lets you take typing
tests and complete free typing
activities
get ready i'm ready place your hands
begin when ready cheryl was invited to
join a choir by her friend when she got
there
she found chaos her friend said this was
normal for the first half hour
cheryl loved to sing and she had a
lovely voice she could also sight read
music very well this would be an asset
to any coral group she joined it was
immediately
obvious that this group was made up of
friends who wanted to visit
but were not too keen on doing the work
needed to make fine music
the choir leader was happy to have such
a serious singer in the group and she
knew that
he would coax her to stay
she figured the only way to withdraw
gracefully was to have the leader tell
her not to come back
so she turned her music
upside down to convince him and the
other members that she had a great voice
but would sing the wrong notes the
leader quickly suggested that she joined
another choir
a semicolon one that would compete with
his choir in the music festival your
errors are highlighted what's my growth
that's not what i want that's not what i
want no a challenge level oh no i'm here
for speed
place your hands over home
[Applause]
give me your godly grace
i'm ready
begin when ready did you know to hear
the material read aloud highlight the
text
why are you here
to hear the material read aloud
highlight the text
[Music]
to hear the material read aloud
highlight the text i highlighted it i
highlighted it i highlighted it
i highlighted it did you know there is a
curious mixed-up animal called the
platypus
the platypus is part mammal and part
bird it has a body like a beaver and a
bill and feet like a duck
a mother platypus gives milk like all
mammal mothers do
she lays eggs like all bird mothers do
there are many other examples of
a challenge
begin when ready
did you know there is a curious mixed up
animal called the platypus
the platypus is part mammal and part
bird
it has a body like a beaver and a bill
and feet like a duck
a mother platypus gives milk like all
mammal mothers do
she lays eggs like all bird mothers do
there are many other examples of furious
creatures in the world the test was
stopped by your errors
114
yes yes yes yes yes
you can try the assessment again by
clicking the redo button i've done it
i did it everyone i did it i will 114
grow speed that's all that matters i'm
the fastest i'm not the fastest but i'm
fast welcome to mavis no no no please no
please skill checks no no what's a tata
snail kids still salt salad a ton of
onions a tour tornado another orn
galston fair practice horn
[Music]
[Music]
this spoken support can be changed or
set to autumn welcome to welcome welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome
well everybody
it's time for a nice arm and shoulder do
you have aching muscles or feel tense
start by raising your hands like the
model you see and wiggle your fingers
shush
thank you all so much for being a part
of this wonderful video where mavis
beacon taught us to type i was not
prepared for it
maybe i'll try the 2020 edition later on
but this was a good blast from the past
remember type with correct posture all
of your comments down below do not
deviate from the home row lest the ghost
of mavis beacon will come and haunt you
for the rest of your is maybe speaking
still alive is maybe speaking a real
person in 2022 seeking mavis beacon a
documentary was released to tell the
story of mavis beacon and its creations
by the men behind the company joe abrams
les crane and walt dilowski
what
[Music]
mavis why are you here
mavis memphis no nervous
it's puzzle time
[Music]
you